BARTON ZWIEBACH: After
this long detour,
you must think that
one is just trying
to avoid doing the real
computation, so here comes,
the real computation.
The real computation is
taking that right hand side
on the top of the blackboard
and trying to just calculate
this right hand side.
So back to the calculation.
The calculation dN/dt
is equal to this thing
over there, integral
dx i over h-bar.
I'll still copy it here-- h
psi-star psi minus psi-star h
psi.
OK.
Well, let's do this.
This whole quantity is d-rho/dt,
and let's see how much it is.
Well, you would have of the
following-- i over h-bar h
psi-star.
Well, h in detail is over
there, so I'll put it here.
Minus h squared over 2m d
second dx squared of psi-star.
So I'm beginning h psi star--
that's from the first term in
the Hamiltonian-- times psi.
And then from the other
term in the Hamiltonian
is the potential, so it would be
plus V of x and t psi-star psi.
V of x and t times
psi-star times psi.
This other term would
be minus psi-star h psi,
so it's going to be opposite
sign to here, so plus h squared
over 2m psi-star d second
dx squared psi, and then
minus psi-star V of x and t psi.
Here, there was a little
thing that I probably
should have said before
is that the potential is
real, that's why it didn't
get complex conjugated here.
H psi would have a term V psi
and we just conjugate the psi.
OK, this is not so bad.
In particular, you see that
these two terms cancel.
So that's neat.
And now, this becomes
the following--
this d-rho/dt has become minus
ih over 2m d second psi-star dx
squared times psi minus psi-star
d second psi dx squared.
OK.
That's what d-rho/dt is and
that's the thing that should be
0 when you integrate--
it doesn't look like
anything equal to 0,
and that was pretty
much to be expected.
So what do we have
to do with this?
Well, we have to
simplify it more,
and what could save us
is, and it's usually
the same thing that saves you
all the time when you want
to show an integral vanishes,
many times, what you show
is that it is a
total derivative.
So remember, we're
computing here d-rho/dt,
which is all this
thing circled here,
and it's to be
integrated over x.
So if I could show this is
a derivative with respect
to x, the total x
derivative, then the integral
would go to the
boundaries and I would
have a chance to make it 0.
So what do we have?
That derivative is
indeed at boundaries,
so d-rho/dt is equal to
minus i h-bar bar over 2m.
And look, this can be
written as d/dx of something
and what is that something?
It's d psi-star dx times psi
minus psi-star d second psi--
no not d second--
d first psi dx.
The nice thing that
happens here is
that if you act
with this d/dx, you
get the second derivative
terms that you had in there.
But you also get derivatives
acting here on d psi
and here on d psi-star,
but those will cancel.
So it's a very
lucky circumstance,
it had better happen, but
this is a total derivative
with respect to x.
And that's just
very a good deal.
So we're going to
rewrite it a little more.
I'll write it as
the following way--
this whole factor is h over 2im,
that's with its sign, output
the d/dx outside--
I'll put an extra minus
sign, so I will flip
the order of these two terms--
psi-star d psi dx minus
psi d psi-star dx.
OK.
Well, in many ways,
the most difficult part
of the calculation
is over and it's now
a matter of giving
proper names to things.
Why do I say that?
Because look, want to
see the finish line?
It's here.
We've shown this whole integrand
is d/dx of that right hand
side.
Therefore, when you
do the integral,
you will have to go to the
boundary with that thing,
so you just need to see what
happens to these quantities
as x goes to infinity.
And as x goes to
infinity, we said
that psi must go to
0 from the beginning.
And d psi dx must not blow
up, so if psi goes to 0
and d psi dx doesn't blow up,
this whole thing goes to 0
and dN/dt is equal
to 0 and you're done.
So you're done
with the conditions
that we mention that
the wave function must
satisfy these conditions.
But let's clean up this,
because we've actually
discovered an important
quantity over there that
is going to play a role.
So here you see that you
have a complex number
minus its complex conjugate.
So this is like z
minus z-star, which
is equal to 2i I times
the imaginary part of z.
If you subtract from a complex
number its complex conjugate,
you get the imaginary part only
survives, but it's twice of it.
So from here, this whole thing
is 2i times the imaginary part
of psi-star d psi dx.
So d-rho/dt is equal
to minus d/dx of what?
Of 2i times the imaginary
part of that, cancels the 2i,
you get h-bar over m imaginary
part of psi-star d psi dx.
And this quantity is going to
be called the current density.
So the current density, you
say, why the current density?
We'll see in a minute.
But let's write it here because
it'll be very important.
J of x and t is h-bar
over m imaginary part
of psi-star d psi dx.
So if this is called
the current density,
you would have an equation
here d-rho/dt is equal to minus
dJ/dx d/dx of J dx, or d-rho/dt
plus dJ/dx is equal to 0.
Now this is called
current conservation.
You've seen it before
in electromagnetism
and we'll review it here
in a second as well.
So look what has happened.
You began with the introduction
of a charged density, which
was a probability density,
but you were led now
to the existence of a current.
And you've seen that
in three dimensions,
more than in one dimension--
I think probably
in one dimension
it doesn't look that
familiar to you,
but let me make sure you will
recognize it in a few seconds.
So think units here first.
Units.
What are the units
of the wave function?
Well, the wave function,
you integrate over x squared
and it gives you 1.
So the integral of psi
squared dx is equal to 1,
so this has units of length,
this must have units of 1
over square root of length.
And what are therefore the
units of psi-star d/dx psi,
which is part of the
current formula ?
Well, 1 of the square
root of length--
1 over square root of length is
one over length and another 1
over length is 1
over length squared.
OK.
And then you have
h-bar, which has
units of mL squared over T.
Probably done that before
already.
And therefore, h over m has
units of L squared over T.
So the current has
units of h over m--
the units of current
has units of h over m,
which is L squared over T--
times units of this whole
thing, which is 1 over L
squared, so at
the end, 1 over T.
And this means just
probability per unit time.
That's the units of current.
Probability has no units, so
we're dealing probability,
those are pure numbers, but this
is probability per unit time.
So probability per unit time.